voilà dix meilleurs élèves qui est le
président ukrainien qui ne revient pas
en Ukraine les mains vies de non
seulement il a eu des discussions très
fructueuses à la crête Chaptal en ce qui
concerne l'accession de l'OTAN de
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN mais aussi il revient
avec ses 5 combattants ces 5 soldats qui
font partie de bataillon Azov un
bataillon extrêmement populaire ici en
Ukraine et surtout ce n'est pas anodin
c'est 5 soldats étaient prisonniers de
guerre en Russie ils avaient été libéré
à la seule condition qui ne remette pas
les pieds en Ukraine avant la fin de la
guerre pourtant ces choses faites ils
sont bien revenu en Ukraine donc ça
montre un Vladimir Poutine affaibli
finalement et c'est une victoire pour
l'Ukraine une victoire apportée par
reapei perd